[Music]  My dear Frodo you asked me once if I had  told you everything there was to know  about my adventures well I can honestly  say I have told you the truth I may not  have told you all of it  Bilbo Baggins I'm looking for someone to  share in an adventure I can't just go  running off into the blue I am a Baggins  right of Bag End turbo allow me to  introduce fili Kili  I'm doing darling Balin bifur Bofur  Bombur Dori nori Ori and the leader of  our company Thorin Oakenshield  the misty  to  to dungeons deep and caverns old the  pines were  [Music]  [Music]  five  it flames  the trees like torture  we can't guarantee his safety  understood no but I'd be responsible for  his fate  [Music]  [Music]  you don't have a tear the two to tell  when you come banner if you promise that  I will come back no and if you do you  will not be discerned  [Music]  my name is Bilbo Baggins  those balances  [Music]